it's okay we got him we got him okay a
former California Sergeant now faces
multiple charges after his alleged
excessive use of force during an arrest
this spring okay we got him I got him
okay put your hands behind your back put
your hands behind your back now are you
gonna get another tase Mercedes 11 we're
4 15 with his individual taser
deployment it happened on March 11th in
Merced County California body camera
video shows officials with the Sheriff's
Office respond to the scene of a car
crash what's going on man
good good
yeah I don't know all right I'll see you
soon today
so what happened
I I try to take
um Belcher honestly for a short way to
go down here but honestly I this road I
swear I just didn't even know where I
was going officials tell the driver
Lewis Jackson that he's
just driving Under the Influence Jackson
can be heard on body camera video
admitting he's drunk be honest with you
okay I'm gonna be transparent with you
okay all right
um just because due to the condition
that
the car went through the fence and stuff
and you did say you had been drinking
but that might have a
um there's no need for a sobriety test
there's nothing right
here okay so look they're they're just
they're gonna do their tests okay but
I'm just wanting I'm not to wasted at
this time there's no need for somebody
I'm drunk okay I've been drinking after
this an argument breaks out and Jackson
is seen lunging toward then Sergeant
Dustin Witt video shows another first
responder pull out a taser
driver to drive the car right not
necessarily
[Applause]
hey so that's not even that's not even
crazy but for you to get out my girl
like that okay bro
after this wit can be seen on video
repeatedly kicking Jackson and stomping
on his head another first responder can
be heard telling Whit to stop after that
Jackson is handcuffed it's okay we got
him we got him okay place your hands
behind your back put your hands behind
your back now are you gonna get another
tase
roll over
roll over hey you stop playing like that
roll over come on
come on
let me start 11 41.
[Applause]
I'm sorry roll over I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry sir
sit up
laughs
video shows these same moments from
wit's perspective okay we got him we got
him okay put your hands behind your back
put your hands behind your back now are
you gonna get another tase Mercedes 11
we're 4 15 with this individual taser
deployment
partner roll over
roll over hey stop playing like that and
roll over roll over come on
come on
Mercer wrestling you start 11 41.
roll over
sit up
Whit resigned from the Merced County
Sheriff's Office this June after an
internal investigation he was charged
with assault by a peace officer an
assault likely to cause great bodily
injury reporting for long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie